I got a DUI 2 days after my 21st
birthday the first time you actually
ever legit went to a bar first time I
ever legit went to a bar I walked to the
bar with my friend Isaac I walked home
and then we decided we were going to go
get some
cigarettes so instead of walking to the
gas station I said I'll take your car we
can
drive um backing the car out of my
driveway I busted the mirror off you
know cuz I was so great to drive and we
just thought it was hilarious uh the
crackhead that lived downstairs from us
was come out and she begged us not to go
do not go do not go a
crackhead it's pretty bad when a
crackhead is B like you should not be
driving h a crackhead ising you hey
please don't
go the Honeydew with y'all subscribe
[Music]
today